so yeah hi everyone
um i'll be talking about a slightly
improved
approximation algorithm for metric tsp
and this is joint work with anna carlin
and
cheyenne obscura um
and yeah before i start the talk i want
to say uh please ask questions if you
have them
i think uh yeah this talk references
some
background that's common maybe in the
area of approximation algorithms
um but maybe not as well known outside
of it so yeah i really welcome
clarification questions
okay so in tsp uh you're giving us input
a list of cities
and they're pairwise symmetric distances
which form a metric
so they obey the triangle inequality
and the goal is to find the minimum cost
tour which visits every city at least
once
so if i live in essen and i want to
visit all the marc cities and then
return home
then tsp will give me the shortest route
which does so
in particular we're looking for any
valid tour so
actually any connected eulerian subgraph
will work as a solution
since such a graph exhibits an eulerian
tour so if we think of our metric as a
complete graph
so we're given the distances between
every vertex
then we're looking to find a minimum
cost connected subgraph where every
vertex has even degree
and for those of you who are curious why
tsp is usually referred to as a
mid hamiltonian cycle it turns out that
these are the same problem
you can always using the triangle
inequality shortcut
and eulerian tour to obtain a
hamiltonian tour of
no no greater cost but for the rest of
this talk i'll i'll be looking just for
a
connected eulerian subgraph
unfortunately tsp is np hard so to solve
complex instances in a reasonable amount
of time
we have to accept finding approximate
solutions
and we say an algorithm has
approximation ratio alpha
if for every instance the cost of its
computed solution
divided by the cost of the optimal
solution is at most alpha
and the best approximation algorithm for
this problem was
from 1976 by christofides and
independently
1978 by sergio akov and has a ratio of
three halves
or in other words it always produces a
tour at most fifty percent longer than
the optimal one
and it does so in polynomial time
and after a long line of work we know
it's np hard to approximate better than
123 over 122. so we sort of have a long
way to go in terms of understanding the
approximability of this problem
these numbers are fairly far apart
many of you may already be familiar with
christopher's algorithm but i
want to show it here as the algorithm we
study is closely related
so here's an example graph we may wish
to find a tsp tour on
or again equivalently a cheap eulerian
subgraph
and in general there are weights on the
edges but here feel free to think of
every edge as having weight one and the
algorithm first chooses a minimum
spanning tree t
making the graph connected however since
there are odd vertices this doesn't
correspond to a tour
every vertex should have even degree
whenever i enter a city i have to leave
it as well
so we add now the minimum cost matching
on the odd degree vertices of the tree
which fixes our problem by making every
vertex even
and now the green and the red edges
together make an eulerian tour
so now let's compute the cost of the
tour clearly it's
the sum of the cost of the tree and the
cost of the matching
um and since opt itself is a tree plus
an edge
the cost of the minimum spanning tree is
certainly less than the cost of out
and now let's look at the matching so i
claim it's at most half the cost of out
to see this consider the odd vertices
highlighted here in red
along the optimal cycle and now due to
the triangle inequality
the restriction of the optimal cycle to
the odd vertices
costs at most out and now since there
are always an even number of odd
vertices
this subtour can be partitioned into two
matchings
here one is in purple and one is in pink
and therefore one of these must cost at
most half of opt
um and a minimum cost matching uh cannot
exceed this cost so that that proves the
second claim
and together this gives us a
three-halves approximation
this is christopher's algorithm
and since then there's been a lot of
amazing progress on approximating tsp
for example in special cases such as
planar tsp
meaning the distances are given by a
planar graph
here we have a one plus epsilon
approximation for any epsilon
and also graphic tsp where distances are
given by an unweighted graph we have a
1.4 approximation
however the general case has remained at
1.5
and recently we made a tiny dent in this
problem and improved upon
christopher's algorithm by some 10 to
the negative 36.
um so i found this meme last year by
jakub tarnowski and you can see we
actually get many many more nines than
is uh is written here so i'm sad to say
we're very far from
making boromir happy but um yeah we'll
we'll keep working
okay so here's an outline of the rest of
the talk
um since this is a workshop on
polynomials i'll sort of
ignore many of the more combinatorial
details
um but in order to convince you that the
tools we develop in section four are
actually useful
for this problem i first need to explain
at least the rough outline of our
approach
so i'll start with some background and
by defining actually the algorithm we
use
the first piece is pretty standard in
the cs world it's this
linear programming relaxation for the
problem
it asks for a fractional hamiltonian
cycle
so this means that every vertex should
have fractional degree two
and every cut should have fraction at
least two
so for example this red cut has value
two
since the dotted edges are one half here
making this a minimum cut
of the support graph this green cut
for example has value three so it's
satisfied but it's not a tight
constraint
in the lp and you can verify that this
graph is a feasible solution since every
cut has value at least two
and this is known as the subtour
elimination lp or the held carp
relaxation
and note that even though i've written
an exponential number of constraints
it can be solved in polynomial time via
a separation oracle
it's easy to find a minimum cut in the
support graph
and just return it as a violated
constraint if it's below two and we can
kind of repeat this process
um and note that this is actually a
relaxation of the problem
the optimal integral solution is itself
feasible for this program
therefore the optimal solution to this
lp is a lower bound on the cost of an op
of an optimal integral tsp solution
so yeah as is often the case it's
convenient to think of xe
as the probability an edge e is in the
tour
so this lp really gives us two benefits
first we get a lower bound on the cost
of opt
and secondly we get a sense for which
edges we might want to put in a tour
here's the second piece of background a
spanning tree distribution is
lambda uniform if every edge has weight
lambda e
and the probability of a spanning tree
is proportional to the product of the
lambda e's in its edge set
so for example the graph on the left
with lambdas one half one and one
would yield the following distribution
over spanning trees
and it was proved in 2010 by assad
portal
that for any point x in the spanning
tree polytope
we can find a lambda uniform spanning
tree distribution in polynomial time
that matches the marginals of x and they
do so using a max entropy
convex program so we can alternately
think of these lambda uniform
distributions
as the distributions which maximize
entropy
subject to the constraint of matching
the marginals of x
so kind of as an aside that many of you
may know
this is actually an instance of a more
general fact
given any probability distribution mu
and any point x
in its newton polytoke there's an
external field lambda
such that the distribution resulting
from applying this external field
matches the marginals of x
and if mu is strongly rally then due to
closure under external fields this means
that for any point x
and mu's newton polytoke there's another
strong neural distribution matching the
marginal specs
and this is a sort of nice general
effect
and just to say one more point on this
slide recall that uh
uniformly random spanish distributions
are sr is there a determinant of measure
and due to closure properties applying
the external field lambda preserves the
sr property
so we know that these lambda uniforms
furniture distributions are
themselves sr which is a fact that we'll
use
okay so now i can define the algorithm
and here we'll study an algorithm which
is based on a work
uh by my co-author cheyenne as well as
siberian singing
and it's also very similar to
christopher's algorithm
okay so first we'll compute an lp
solution
x to the hellcat relaxation
and then given this x we'll compute a
marginal preserving lambda uniform
spanning true distribution mu
on the support graph of x um and there
is a small issue here which is that the
lp solution x is in the tsp polytope
not the spanning tree polytope um but it
it turns out this is easy
it's easy to convert a point in the tsp
polytope to one on this branch you
polytope sort of without loss
so this is this is not an issue
and now we choose a spanning tree t from
mu at random
and do this marginal preserving property
in expectation it costs it most out
and finally as in christopher's
algorithm we just add the minimum cost
matching
m on the odd degree vertices of the tree
so our goal now is to use properties of
our tree
to show that the cost of the matching is
less than half of opt in expectation
and since the tree costs the most opt
this would show that this is a
randomized
1.5 minus epsilon approximation for tsp
i want to give some quick intuition on
why it's important to find a lambda
uniform distribution
not just any convex combination of trees
so here's a bad example although there
are many um
so suppose we're looking at the unit
metric meaning every point has distance
one from every other point
and suppose our lp solution is this
complete graph on n vertices with
two over n minus one on every edge
then a valid marginal preserving
distribution
is to write the point as a convex
combination of n stars
but now in every tree we sample
every vertex has odd degree and
therefore every matching costs n over
two
so this is this would not work but it
seems like i kind of picked an
adversarial distribution
uh so the hope is that if we pick a
distribution which is entropy maximizing
we might on average get something better
and yeah i think personally i think
lambda uniform trees also turn out to
look
sort of less like stars and more like
trees we find in nature
and a little more formally it turns out
that
when we sample from a lambda uniform
distribution
we actually get trees that are so-called
locally hamiltonian
meaning that many vertices have degree
two in the tree and you know
pairs of vertices have some chance of
both being degree two and
and so on
and this yeah so this might already give
you some hope that this
the algorithm works since the optimal
solution we're looking for is itself a
hamiltonian cycle
and now the tree already kind of looks
like one
and we can prove this occurs by using
the fact that lambda uniform
distributions
are sr as i already mentioned
um okay so i'll use this notation uh
delta of s sub t to denote the number of
edges
in the tree in the cut delta of s
and uh a well-known fact about sr
distributions is as follows which
i'll state for spanning trees but it's
true in general
uh so for any cut s there exists some
number of independent bernoullis
b1 through bm such that the law of the
size of the intersection of this cut
with the tree is equal to the law of the
sum of these bernoullis
so in other words for any k the
probability the number of edges this cut
shares with the tree is k
is exactly given by the probabilities
these bernoullis some decay
and this gives us a pretty nice constant
it says that for any cut with
expectation
close to two it's even with probability
at least
around 0.43 and since vertices have
x of delta of s equal to 2 this says
many of them are even
giving us this locally hamiltonian
property
in fact many of them are degree 2 but
recall that since the matching is only
over odd vertices really the important
thing
is that the vertices have even degree
not really that they just have degree
two
so i want to just pause on this fact for
a moment um
because although the proof is quite
simple it's the kind of bound we don't
see
very often so these bernoullis actually
let us talk about
the parody of a random variable and get
quite a good bound on it um and it turns
out it's
quite important we get a good bound um
we can't actually tolerate a number much
below
0.43 in our proof uh and if we only use
concentration and say got a bound on the
probability of vertex
at exactly degree two that would not be
enough for us
so yeah long story short many cuts are
even i'm
very thankful for this bernoulli fact uh
and if you don't want to listen to the
whole talk i would say you could stop
here and just sort of take away this
fact and the locally hamiltonian
property
and you know maybe you could convince a
friend that this algorithm might work
although obviously this is far from our
proof
so given this intuition i'll talk a
little more formally about
how we actually analyze the cost of the
matching
okay so remember we want to find the
minimum cost matching
on the odds degree vertices of the tree
and now to bound the cost we'll use this
matching linear program
so basically instead of computing the
expected cost of an integral matching
this is a pretty hard thing to get a
handle on we want to instead show an
upper bound on the expected cost of a
fractional matching
between the odd vertices of the tree so
here's the lp and here's an example tree
we might want to augment with a matching
and here the odd degree vertices are
marked in red
so clearly you want to minimize the cost
and your variables are non-negative
so let's make sense of the second
constraint
basically if you select a cut who's set
who's cut
if you select a set whose cut has an odd
number of edges in the tree
then by degree sum arguments the number
of odd vertices in that cut
must be odd so one of them must be
matched
outside the set letting us add this
constraint
this set on the other hand has no such
constraint
because these two vertices could be
matched to one another
so this is the same thing as looking at
sets with an odd number of odd vertices
in the tree
and this lp is a very nice property it
has an integrality gap of 1
and this means that if we can construct
a fractional matching of cost c
this means there must exist an integral
matching of cost at most c
and since we just run a minimum cost
matching we'll definitely find a
matching of cost at most c
so now the game is to find a cheap
fractional solution to this lp
at least in expectation and then our
integral matching is guaranteed to find
something
at least that cheap
any questions about the sort of overall
strategy
okay
um and just to be clear about what i
mean when i say even and odd
i'm going to use this as a kind of
shorthand we'll say a cut is even
if it's edges have even intersection
with the tree and odd otherwise
and again this corresponds to whether or
not these cuts have constraints in the
matching lp
it turns out it's very easy to get a
matching of cost at most
opt over 2 has increased the feed is but
only by looking at this lp
so if we set y e is equal to xe over 2
for all edges
this is already feasible since every cut
has at least fraction 2 and the tsp lp
and therefore in this solution every cut
has at least fraction one
so we actually just using the solution
we satisfy
every cut in the matching lp not just
these odd ones
and this costs half of the lp of the
tsplp
and so we immediately recover this three
halves approximation
however as i said this assignment simply
makes every cut at least one
so we're actually satisfying constraints
that might not exist
so the hope now is maybe if a lot of
cuts have an even intersection with the
tree
and hence many constraints just
disappear from this lp
then perhaps we can set y e to be
strictly less than x e over two in
expectation
for example if some edges magically
happen to be in no odd cuts
and therefore no constraints we could
set their y e values to be
zero uh so yeah if we can gain some
epsilon with respect to this initial
feasible solution
then we would obtain a three-halves
minus epsilon approximation
okay so as i said we can think of this
xc over two solution
as our initial point and now we will
perturb it a little bit
by applying a slack vector that depends
on the tree
such that we set y e to be xe over two
plus this slack
and the slack may be positive or
negative
but we want it to be negative in
expectation
so think of us as starting at a feasible
point and then taking a small step in a
direction which in expectation
makes every slack negative in other
words sending the expected value of
every y e down
and so as long as s of e always keeps y
feasible this implies that our matching
costs less than half of opt
so now our goal is just to construct an
s with these properties
that's also feasible
and in order to help us maintain
feasibility our third criteria is that
our slack vector will be very
sort of subtle we'll move variables by a
tiny fraction eta
at most guaranteeing that each slack is
at least
negative eight over four times xe with
probability one
it turns out that this third criteria
lets us ignore all constraints in the
matching lp
that correspond to large cuts in x
uh in fact the only constraints we're
concerned with now
given this feasibility requirement have
x of delta of s
less than two plus two eta so if you
take any cut that's larger
then uh due to condition three even if
you set every
every slack in that cut to be minimal
this constraint would still be satisfied
so we never have to worry about large
cuts now
so for the rest of the talk we'll only
be concerned with the small cuts
i wish i'll call the near minimum cuts
and i say near minimum because our lp
ensures every cut is at least two so
basically we're looking at constraints
that are very very close to being tight
um an eta here will be a very small
constant you may wish to think of it as
you know being even zero okay
so yeah since we generate negative slack
from these
sort of missing constraints in the
matching lp it's very crucial that many
of these constraints corresponding to
near minimum cuts are actually missing
so if all the constraints were there the
lp would just return the same value so
this approach only works for
distributions then expectation
have many even near minimum cuts
so to go back to our example we now care
about these sort of red cuts
which are near minimum cuts of the lp
but we don't care about these green cuts
which have value much greater than two
and note the vertices themselves are
also minimum cuts so we need to worry
about these as well
so in remembering the star example we
might say that another reason this
distribution failed
is because it had no chance of making
the near minimum cuts of the graph even
in particular in this graph the near
minimum cuts are only the degree cuts
and in every single tree we sample every
near minimum cut is odd
however as we already know in our
distribution many near minimum cuts
should be even
in fact 0.43 of the vertices should be
and this would yield a matching cost
below 1 over 3.
so this is not a bad example for our
algorithm
and in general if we have a graph where
the only near minimum cuts are degree
cuts
it turns out it's not hard to show that
this algorithm works
so in this case we can use a lemma which
was proved in the paper from
obvious quran and siberian sing in 2010
that any two near minimum cuts are even
simultaneously with probability at least
some constant p
and there is one important exception
hence the star
but i'm not going to go into that in
this talk
but given this the degree cut cases is
now easy
um pick any edge e it's only in two near
minimum cuts it's
it's endpoints then with probability p
the tree that's picked has even
intersection with both of its endpoints
due to this lemma
and in other words this is saying that
with probability at least p
any edge e is in no odd near minimum
cuts
and in this case we can set its slack to
be negative eight over four
because all the constraints for small
cuts are gone
and remember we don't care about big
cuts
and now each slack has negative
expectation
it's zero if an endpoint is odd and
negative eta over 4 times
xc otherwise so the degree cut case is
is good
however this strategy meaning setting
slack to be negative if an edge is in no
odd near minimum cuts and zero otherwise
cannot work in general
some edges may be in many many near
minimum cuts
and this could imply that their slacks
are never set below zero
and these edges and many near minimum
cuts may sort of be the expensive
ones
however hope is not lost maybe if we can
obtain a laminar family
of near minimum cuts where at each level
we just have degree cuts
then maybe we can apply this logic at
every level
and somehow just deal with edges that
appear in many levels
and this is exactly what we do we show
that there's essentially a reduction
into the case
in which the near minimum cuts form a
laminar family
but i won't talk about this since it's
not at all related to
geometry or polynomials but given this
hierarchy
we can now exploit properties of
strongly rally distributions
to construct a slack vector that works
on any laminar family of cuts
so i'll briefly describe this inductive
approach before introducing our two
tools
so here's a valid hierarchy we might
obtain
and now an edge's height is just defined
by the level of the hierarchy that
contains both of its endpoints
so here the pink edges are higher than
the red and the blue edges and the
purple edges are
higher than the pink edges and so on
and at a high level what we'll now do is
as follows
we'll initialize all slack at zero and
then we'll define
local conditions for decreasing slack
we'll decrease an edge's slack when it
is in no odd cuts on its top level
and this matches the intuition that we
perform induction over the degree cut
case
so for example the top level of these
pink edges
is this pink cut and now when we view
this pink cut in isolation
as a graph with only degree cuts viewing
these green sets as
uh contracted points
and for these pink edges these green
cuts are the top two cuts
terminology i'll be using for this
section and now the pink edges local
condition
is the same as in the degree cut case we
reduce their slack when both of these
green cuts are even
this reduction may unfortunately need to
trigger increases
in other edges slack that we're down in
the hierarchy
we only did a sort of very local
conditioning
but basically trading off between these
local decreases and these more global
increases
is basically the essence of our approach
so more formally we decrease slack for
this local reason
if an edge's top two cuts and the
hierarchy are even
so for example look at our pink edge e
l2 and r2 are its top two cuts in the
hierarchy
so if the black edges represent the
sampled tree
here we would not reduce the slack of
the pink edge as both l2 and r2 were odd
l2 has three edges and r2 is one edge
however if we sample this tree instead
then both cuts are even so now we can
reduce se
by its maximum possible reduction
this is the decrease of n
however we only condition on l2 and r2
being even
we only look sort of very locally around
us and we don't know whether l1
and r1 are even or not and if they're
odd
these constraints are actually violated
in the matching lp
since they were nearly tight to begin
with and we decreased the value of an
involved variable
so what we'll do is actually increase
the slack
of other edges to make up for this issue
for this decrease of e
so in this case r1 is odd so we must
increase
some f i to make up for ease reduction
l1 is even so no increase is needed
and what we'll end up doing is
performing a matching such that whenever
e
is reduced and a cut lower in the
hierarchy containing e is odd
then an edge group of similar fractional
value will increase
so here say f3 is matched to e and they
have a similar fractional value
then we guarantee that whenever e is
decreased
and r1 is odd we increase the slack of f
to fix this constraint
something important to keep in mind is
that if an edge is reduced
it definitely does not have to increase
its slack for any edge going higher
and this is because it only has to
potentially increase slack for its top
two cuts
but the decrease event implies that both
of these cuts are actually even
so the increase and decrease events are
disjoint
and it only remains to show that the
expected decrease of an edge is greater
than its expected increase
and i think of the increase event as
sort of a global response to these vocal
decrease events
and this is because the decrease event
may trigger sort of thousands of
increase events
um so in this example you can think of e
as being in many many cuts
and when it's decreased you know maybe
all these red cuts are odd
even though e's top cut is even so this
decrease on e
may trigger the increase of of many many
other edges
okay so i i won't go into too much more
detail than that
um either fortunately or unfortunately
depending on
how bored you are but to summarize
we first want to find good local
conditions under which we decrease slack
and i mentioned the condition that we
reduce when it edge's top two cuts are
even
but it turns out we often need to go
beyond that and provide stronger
guarantees
and then we want to bound the
probability that edges need to increase
to compensate for reductions on other
edges going higher
and this involves proving bounds on the
parity of cuts
conditioned on the slack of other edges
being reduced
so basically we want to understand the
probability that one of these cuts
sort of lower down on the hierarchy is
even
conditioned on e being reduced
and to get a handle on these two points
we proved two limits about strongly
rally distributions that
may be of independent interest
okay so we first proved that for any k
disjoint sets
each with expectation close to one
there's a constant probability that each
set has intersection one with the tree
so in this example there's a constant
probability that each color has exactly
one edge
more formally we prove a generalization
of a lemma from a paper by gerbitz from
we show that if you have k disjoint sets
and their expectation is close to the
all ones vector
then the probability that every set has
intersection one
with the tree is a function of only k
and epsilon i'm using t
and tree here but again this holds for
general
sr distributions and i call this a
generalization
as this was previously known for k
subsets that each had
expectation exactly one and now we allow
some deviation
and recently as we saw in jonathan's
talk on wednesday
uh gervais and weak grouped a related
theorem which has a much better
dependence on k
and allows deviation up to 2 but only
holds for homogeneous distributions
so for now these are sort of
incomparable
but maybe they'll be able to remove this
homogeneous criteria
and our lemma is actually stated in
terms of probabilities
so here's its alternate form
and it can actually be generalized to
sets of any size not just size one but
i'm stating it for sort of sets of
expectation
each close to 1. and having a
probability
here is useful since in some cases we
don't have a bound on the expectation
but we can still prove something about
these probabilities
and just to quickly highlight the
differences between these two lemmas
although you should see jonathan's talk
for a lot more detail
basically our lemma works for
non-homogeneous distributions
and again uses probabilities instead of
expectations
but the bound is much worse we get this
doubly exponential thing
um and i also want to mention that their
proof
seems to use sort of the right tools
going more through the geometry of
polynomials
so i think there's some hope it can be
extended to get um
epsilon's decay in our regime whereas
our proof technique
uh seems maybe more unlikely to get to
get this bound
um and i want to point out that
requiring these ais to be disjoint
is a huge issue for us um in fact
they're never disjoint in our
applications
as we're always talking about a
collection of cuts that all share a
particular edge
that we want to get a local condition
for
so basically we always end up doing some
you know strange
kind of manual work where we first do
some conditioning to make these ai
disjoint
and then we apply this theorem and when
we do the conditioning we have to kind
of bound the
the changes on the ai's yeah so this is
not ideal and this suggests the question
is there good
for characterization of the necessary
disjointness conditions
on these ai um so it seems we sort of
understand
uh disjoint sets now but we don't have
precise tools
for sets that overlap i think this is a
good open question
so why is this useful um basically
instead of only proving that the top two
cuts of an edge are even
with constant probability we now want to
go farther
and prove stronger local conditions such
as the top four cuts being even
say for this pink edge we want you know
l1 l2
r2 and r1 to all be even simultaneously
and this is useful because it just means
that less
increase needs to occur previously we
had to increase
on the r1 cut for the pink edge whenever
it was reduced and r1 was odd
but now that never happens whenever the
pink edge is reduced we're guaranteed
that r1 is even
in some sense this lemma lets us talk
about any k cuts simultaneously
however due to the disjointness issue
it's difficult to characterize
exactly when we can get all k cuts to be
even with constant probability
for instance there are even some counter
examples for k equals two
um so actually obtaining these local
conditions can be a bit tricky
okay and second we prove a related fact
for two disjoint sets
a and b and the expectation again close
to
one we show that there's an event of
constant measure
which approximately preserves the
marginals of all the edges in a
and b and guarantees that when this
event occurs
a and b each have intersection one with
the tree
so for example conditioned on this event
you know a and b
are both one and we know the marginals
of this pink edge
so the probability using t condition on
this event
is still approximately one half
and here it is written formally for any
two
disjoint sets a and b with expectation
close to one
there's a marginal preserving event e of
a b
of constant measure in which
each of a and b have intersection one
with a tree
and again these total variation
distances are preserved up to
factor epsilon and this epsilon we can
get here
depends on the distance of a and b from
one
okay and so now how do we use this
uh suppose that we can align an edge's
local condition
with this lemma uh and it turns out that
if an edge's top two cuts look like this
picture
where they both share fraction one then
we can do exactly that
here e is even exactly when the top two
cuts
sorry here e is even and it's top two
cuts exactly when a and b
have intersection one with the tree
and using this we can obtain more
control over this more
sort of global impact of reducing an
edge's slack
um and this gives us yeah this gives us
a lot of control so while under some
local conditions
the distribution may change quite a bit
whenever we can apply this second tool
uh to get a an edges decrease event we
know that basically the distribution is
unchanged
so to go back to our picture basically
with this lemma condition on the
reduction of ease slack
any cut lowered down in the hierarchy
still has a
0.43 chance of being even because we've
preserved marginals and actually
it turns out that we preserve the
strongly rally property for
every cut below this edge
whereas without this lemma it can be
difficult to get any bound of this
probability
it can be difficult to even say that the
probability this cut s is even
is greater than say .01
and one issue we have is that this lemma
cannot be used in every instance
and in those cases we have to more
manually sort of ensure that the cuts
lower in the hierarchy
have some chance of being even so
another open question
is to characterize exactly which
situations
where we can approximate where we can
approximately preserve marginals
and the marginal preservation may not
need to even be that close
in fact for us even preserving marginals
up to say a constant multiplicative
factor
could be kind of interesting i think
this is also a good
tool to think about generalizing
um so yeah with these ideas and some
elbow grease
we get a small improvement for tsp
so here's some open directions um so
first
we would like to improve probabilistic
tool number one
in a few ways the most natural question
is
um can we get this tight bound of
epsilon to the k and uh yeah maybe
pyruvates and leak can do this
and the second is whether it's possible
to characterize the necessary
disjointness condition
for this lemma to hold as i said we
mostly got around this problem by first
doing some conditioning
and then applying the lemma on the
resulting disjoint sets um but we think
there should be
some clean description of when it works
and when it doesn't work
um and finally we ask whether it can be
generalized to
log concave distributions
and secondly we ask if uh probabilistic
tool number two
can be generalized to any number of sets
so i stated for two sets
but we uh we think maybe it works for
any number of
disjoint sets then
sort of what trade-off can be obtained
between the distance of these sets from
the all ones vector
and the total total variation distance
or maybe some other measure
um of the marginals from
yeah of the marginals in the resulting
event
and finally we ask whether there's some
totally new way of analyzing this
algorithm
so empirically the algorithm seems to do
quite well
and we know no example where it does
worse than four-thirds
however our analysis seems doomed to uh
only be three-halves by a small constant
so our main question is
whether there's a new approach we can
get something significantly better than
three halves
or maybe an example where the algorithm
doesn't do so well
yeah so with that thanks a lot for
listening and for having me
here's a picture of some tsp soup by
bosch so i'd be happy to take any
questions
thanks a lot nathan it's a really great
talk any any questions
we cannot hear you milana
i was not speaking oh sorry i thought
you were sick
it was it
so in this area there's some conjecture
about the what the optimal approximation
ratio should be right
uh so is it is there any prospect of
these techniques getting close to that
yeah so the
conjectured bound is four thirds um
i think you would need some totally new
ideas
yeah um probably we can't do much better
than
like 1.49 or something yeah because you
comment on where this
like what the weakest part of the
argument is in terms of the constant
like yeah so there's basically
two the the first is that we only look
at
uh these cuts between two and two plus
eta
and the bound you get cannot be better
than three halves minus eta
so immediately you'd wanna
look at cuts that are much much bigger
than just near minimum cuts
so that's one issue and then the second
issue is that
even now given this
these very small cuts we still don't
have a good argument
to get anything close to eta so we we
get you know three halves minus like 10
to the negative 20 times eta or
something like this
so um you'd have to really improve both
of those pieces
by quite a lot but yeah and it's very
unforgiving you'd have to get like one
times eight hour or something yeah
exactly okay
it's uh yeah or maybe like one half but
yeah it's like
pretty um but i think the like that the
really fundamental thing
is uh just you know how big are these
cuts you're looking
at uh i think it'd be interesting to
look at yeah maybe cuts as big as like
three and
see what happens but so does laminar
family stuff doesn't work for the
for is does that break down when you
look at bigger cuts
it's i think it works up to like some
sort of reasonable sounding eta um but
you know nothing probably bigger than
like one over 100 or something
um but the ada we choose also has some
implications for the other argument and
the other argument
uh we need ada to be very very very
small so yeah there's a lot
just sort of a lot of constraints going
on here um
yeah but one um
direction we're kind of interested in is
sort of taking the
um dependence on ada out of the second
argument
in some way and uh that i think that
could be
you know couldn't get four thirds but
maybe you could get maybe we could make
boromir happy you could get like
1.4999999 or something
yeah so we'll see
i think one constraint is that ada must
be less than the probability
the probability that multiple cuts are
even at the same time
which is some sort of this double
exponential that we have
so eta must be less than that the
approximation factor is
less than the product of the two right
uh-huh
so uh that's the simplest so even if you
improved it to exponential
like in this leak and gorgeous thing i
would still
you know it would still yeah it helps
but not so much
okay well thanks again so the next talk
will be at 10.